i have a question a quick question about
consciousness and this and then i have
to leave pretty soon or my wife will
kill okay okay so consciousness this
trickster element you mentioned now at
the same time there's also steve greer i
believe it's grier who said that
there's a project called ce5 or at least
a
uh a technique of ce5 of connecting
yourself with an alien via some
meditative technique or perhaps even
psychedelic some trans state some
abnormal consciousness state altered
state
what do you make of
this all right
well i think one thing about well let me
say one thing about stephen greer i i've
never met the man um um i do take my hat
off to him he's done some incredible
work early on
uh he's not a big fan of our
organization at all and i'm not quite
sure why uh but he isn't but as far as
what he's doing with ce5 and what have
you i
i don't have any comment on that i i i
don't go that far i mean it's
tom you wanna yeah my feeling um
is that you know again
if you look at just what we've done as
human beings over the past hundred years
where it's like we first you know we
invent the telephone and then radio
waves and communicating over different
frequencies and then we're able to tap
phones and we're able to tap you know
hack into radio whatever like you just
look at the progression that we're doing
i would bet money
that down the line when we're
technologically advanced we're gonna not
be hacking radio waves we're going to be
hacking minds we're going to be
listening in to what people are thinking
and
what is the loudest that someone can be
when they're thinking i would imagine
it's a group of people that are that are
meditating together they're all thinking
the same thing at the same moment you
know so it's almost like if you're
searching around for a light in the dark
that's a brighter light
so part of me
really does subscribe to
um you know consciousness and meditation
and the focusing of one's mind um
is being something that
that something advanced could easily get
into i mean you when you look at the
evidence or you look at the data of the
people involved it's you know you can be
paralyzed or you hear voices in your
head or you know there's it's always
something to do
with you know kind of hacking the system
to a degree um so i i think that that's
all plays a big part of it and uh and i
definitely believe it you know i just
think that it needs to be studied
scientifically
yeah i agree i i don't discount what
stephen grier is saying i i i you know
it could possibly be true i just don't
know enough about it uh um uh but
but i applaud that he's actually working
on it but you know